I think a lot of
um women stay with men I think young
like when I was young I was like no I'll
never tolerate a man cheating or
whatever but it's harder when you're in
a relationship especially when you're
emotionally involved for you to just up
and leave I think modern women like
being cheated on do you think but that's
because but that's because modern women
think men are monogamous
one out of three men are either virgins
or haven't had sex in the past year if
you wanted a man that didn't cheat you
could find one pretty yes but they're
the ones that you're not attracted to
you right right monogamous men that
often might not cheat on you aren't the
ones that women are attracted to because
women like men that are like alcohol
well women find 80 of men unattractive
so most women are sleeping out of their
league or dating out of their league and
so if you choose to do that that's what
comes with it yeah and most of them guys
that everyone goes for is going to be a
select pack yeah yeah that's but that's
the thing yeah so I'm saying like if we
like those guys how can we be mad that
they cheat because there's lots of guys
don't and I think this is the problem is
because in society now where we don't
allow men to be polygamous especially in
the Western countries and then that's
the men that are often caught in
cheating and families are breaking
whereas like parts of Asia and Africa
where polygamies a lot more accepted men
have their children multiple wives and
they raise them and their society is a
lot more stable why don't you think that
the owners should be on the men to know
what they can and cannot do so for me if
you know that you're a man who wants to
have multiple women you should know what
you want and you should make that clear
100 so 100 I don't I'm not here for you
being in a monogamous relationship I've
had guys say that where they're in a
monogamous relationship they cheat and
then they come and tell me Well by
Nature our men are not me yeah then you
should have known that you should not be
in anyone yeah a caveat though I think
most of the modern men don't want a
second wife they want a side piece so
they want to remain monogamous to the
one that they love but they have the
local news
you know what's crazy that there are
women who want open relationships too so
you just have to find that for me but
for me I have an issue with dishonesty
when you when a woman communicates to
you and lets you know that she just
wants she wants to monogamy and you say
I want that too but then that's not the
reality of what you're living because
there are women there's there's somebody
for everybody so if you want Hunter if
you want to be with someone and you
don't want to be tied down I think women
in a different age now where a lot of
women don't actually want to be tied
down too so you can easily find that but
I think that women aren't honest with
ourselves and like kind of lie because
I'm sorry A lot of times girls will date
a guy and they know he's a cheater yeah
they know he gets girls it's like what
did you think would happen even even
there's a lot of women that entertain
men that are in relationships or yeah
married or even you know there's there
was a guy that actually like he's he
speaks on uh polygamy well polygeny so
the man being able to have multiple not
women and um so he recently sort of
messaged me about you know would I
insane him and I said does your person
know
you know that's your status and he was
like no I said why would I intern a man
who speaks about it but isn't practicing
it do you get what I mean like if you
come correct that's something I can
consider if it's a part of my lifestyle
but if you're gonna lie and then lie
like why would I be entertaining that
also that's not really Genie if your
partner is not aware yeah
they are very aware of their position
they're very aware that there's
otherwise there's other girlfriends
stuff like that exactly sir you're
cheating yeah exactly do you think if we
accept cheating the first time you're
basically saying it's okay for the rest
yeah yes
because I feel like if you accept it the
first time and you said okay you can
cheat and I will stay then why would he
not do it again but I feel like a man
will cheat regardless whether you stay
or you don't because you could be then
technically single and you will go back
and forth with him for months or years
now
I think that I don't think staying the
first time will enable like will mean he
can carry on doing he's going to get
away with that I think that people are
first of all people are humans I think
that when we get in relationships we
have this idea of like ownership with
people and I think that is I think
that's a that's not a good thing so
people are humans humans make mistakes
and I think sometimes as well
unfortunately some people don't know
what they have until you're at the point
of kind of losing it and there are some
men who they cheat one time and they
realize that actually like why did I do
that kind of like that doesn't I could
lose they realize what they have and
they what they could lose and so it kind
of it change that they don't cheat again
I know I've been like that but at the
same time even two years you'll do the
same thing again I don't believe that
because I know real life men who have
cheated once I don't know
they get better right 50 50 years if you
want to be like married long term 50
years is a long time people are their
habits
feel like men cheat more when you tell
them not to or when you put pressure for
them to have to be monogamous
when women talk about Alpha but oh those
are not the men that we like well the
two men that cheated on me I want to
call them I made them the alpha period
so they weren't somebody that those
Ordinary People one was really obese it
wasn't like anybody that anybody else
would want
um
so as far as I'm concerned if a man's
gonna cheat they're gonna cheat that is
a word because some because everybody's
learned about this Alpha you can get a
man that's like an ordinary everyday man
like what they were and according to how
you are as a woman you make them your
Alpha so nobody was looking at them as
an alpha you know it's some guys and
that that is such a word because some
guys are not what Society what a lot of
women see as desirable but I think I
think there's something in menu that
when a woman likes them they just think
oh I feel like it makes them feel like
yeah and so then they start walking in
that spirit and then they think I can do
anything I want to do
what what you're basically saying is
that you understand why men behave the
way to behave when you still get angry
at the way they behave
no because think about this way here and
this is where societies geared towards
women like men have to sacrifice what
they have to do naturally to conform to
what a woman wants a man wants to spread
his seed that's what he's driven to do
so no that's what he's driven to do so I
always say that men should have practice
discipline I've done so myself because I
know it's important to successful
monogamous relationships however because
women are given sex like you're born of
value in terms of the sexual Marketplace
a man has to earn his right to have sex
so when he sees an opportunity he's
going to take it more time as if he
lacks discipline and can I just say
that I believe that most of the time
it's nobody wants these men until he's
got a woman yeah
and it's not like the women don't know
oh he's got he's got he's got a woman
if he didn't have a woman I don't think
that they would want that man but it's
just that they always want a man that
somebody else is gone
that just makes it easy for the men to
cheat yeah it's pre-selection like so
historically like we wanted men that got
other women because it was a sign that
he could take care of us too if he could
take care of them and that's the thing
coming back to Eddie's point I think
what Society doesn't realize is that men
don't have to cheat if you want multiple
partners that you're going to be
responsible for which I think is
possible you need to be honest and do it
but it's this whole okay I can jump from
this girl to this yeah I can have a kid
I don't think most men want two wives
That's like two headaches
behaved there's nothing worse than
having two of you in one place this is
this is the problem with men you don't
want it because you can't handle it but
then you don't want to be monogamous if
you can't be monogamous be single don't
be with one person why
would they why would they have to why
would they like I mean I'm sorry if
you're in the top 10 20 of guys they
don't have to just be single they can
have them no then fine and they get no
but yeah when they can get a girlfriend
cheat on her and we just talk to the
panel y'all stay no no but this is
perfect
this is the problem it's not that it's
not that you need to have a girlfriend
and cheat on you have a girlfriend and
tell her I'm not monogamous so if you
want to be with me and I give you these
perks yeah but why would he do that when
he can just cheat on you and y'all but
this isn't but then when you get the
toxic behavior from her don't moan when
she then vandalizes your whole property
okay okay why do we why do we put our
bad decisions on demand okay isn't that
like you're just toxic because it's
because I like I've I've been cheated on
before it wasn't it wasn't fun but I
never did anything toxic or crazy or any
any of the [ __ ] that I hear girls say
that that's a you that's a you problem
no man no man can make you do crazy you
should hear either crazy or you're not
no do you know what it is for me
personally I don't call it crazy things
I just [ __ ] I call it disrespect and
reacting to disrespect okay for example
I feel like when a woman doesn't react
and a man cheats and he gets away with
it he doesn't learn that this has hurt
or impacted someone when a woman then
reacts he has to either have discussions
with her or he needs to realize right
this was a reproduction of it okay but
but in these situations everyone reacted
and on the couch
I'm saying even you reacted you were
going through his phone you were telling
him like whatever and and like looking
at his messages or I can't remember
exactly how you said you found out so
you did react he didn't learn his lesson
because he had like a million side
pieces no no no but he never
confirmed that he cheated or anything
but that's what I'm saying and my
reactions were they yeah when I first
left when I left when I first got the
okay this must be confirmation because
of obviously all the girls
yeah I reacted to that yeah and he was
like I can't tolerate this cool and then
I left him but then he did write me
letters saying he wants me back
sorry I just want to say it I don't
think I don't think you necessarily need
to react because I know you made a point
about reacting for him to understand
that this is wrong because I don't react
like the way you react I think that's
this is how I react to things if you do
something that's wild that's crazy
disrespectful to me I'm sorry cool
that's what you've done and I keep you
moving so with me in my situation I did
I didn't react I let you know that okay
this is what you did this is not on it's
not something I want to stand for and I
kept it moving and years later he's
still wanting to have me back yeah but I
don't think you need to necessarily
react to get to let a guy understand
what he's doing wrong yeah and I also I
agree what you said earlier where you
said how because I think I hear a lot of
women sometimes say stuff like oh he
made me crazy
you're either either you're either crazy
or you're not okay
so my point is
refer to it as a woman reacting to it
however she reacts for me I wouldn't say
it's crazy because I feel like Society
say oh it's crazy that's her reaction
that's crazy
no but what exactly I'm saying it's her
expressing her emotions and she's
enraged and raised
coming out you guys wait you're not
you're not a child you're a grown adult
I'm sorry if you need to stop stop
interrupting me you're not a child
you're a grown adult if you make if you
do something crazy you're crazy you
can't blame it on other people like
nobody can make you do anything like
that that's that's like what a child
would say I think can I just haven't
really spoken but I just want to say an
observation that I've made in this
conversation so the younger ladies have
proven a point which I don't know if
anyone's noticed they looked for a
problem they wound themselves up Auntie
said she experienced a similar thing but
she didn't wind herself up she responded
to the situation as the situation
happened and she didn't go in there like
I'm gonna do this I'm gonna do that I
didn't go looking for it like you said
yeah so the difference is within the
modern women
we're looking for the problem and when
we amp ourselves up in the situation
we're actually reacting before we get to
the point